- Truth, who was the last
person you made out with
and how long ago?
(laughing)
- It was last night.
- Okay, yeah!
(upbeat music)
(logo whooshing)
- [Hinano] Hi.
- I'm Carlos.
- Hinano.
- Nice to meet you.
- I'm 25, I'm from Santa Monica.
I was born in Tokyo, Japan
and I am 27 years old.
I'm feeling excited but also nervous.
And I don't know what I'm in store for.
- I'm feeling not as cool,
'cause I wasn't born in Japan,
which is pretty awesome.
- Santa Monica's pretty cool.
- Let's do it.
- Let's play some games.
- Truth or dare.
- Gonna go with truth.
- What is a Physical trait
of mine that you like.
- Your eyes, they're very beautiful eyes.
- Thank you.
- The color, everything.
Truth or dare.
- Truth.
- All right, what was your
first impression of me?
- First impression well I
definitely saw your tattoos, and
- From this side.
- I was like, yeah this
guy he's a little wild.
Truth or dare.
- Dare.
- Always the first one.
- First dare, I dare you to do, oh,
this is a good one, do
10 push-ups shirtless.
- Oh, (beeps) okay.
- Whew!
Whew!
(giggles)
whew!
- I believe that's 10.
(clapping)
- Amazing, how's that little workout.
- It was okay, yeah, I feel little parched
but other than that, I'm good.
(both laughing)
Truth or dare.
- I'm gonna go with the truth.
- Okay, truth, who was the
last person you made out with,
and how long ago was that?
- Ah, (laughs)
- Uh oh.
- it was last night.
- Okay, yeah, I'm glad I
didn't get that question,
good for you.
- It was a first date with
someone I met on a dating app.
- Mm hm, how'd it go?
- It was actually, honestly ended badly,
we weren't on the same wavelength, at all.
- Okay, nice, nice.
- Truth or dare?
- Let's do dare.
- I dare you to, (gasps) what!
Get pied in the face with whipped cream.
- All right.
- I have a plate full of whipping cream.
Ready to pie Carlos.
This is like one of those things
your just supposed to like
- Just do it.
- Just.
(both laughing)
- Oh God.
That's delicious.
- How's that taste?
- That's not the reduced fat,
it might be but it tastes good.
- You know I will do a dare too.
- Okay, I dare you to stare at me
for 30 seconds forehead to forehead.
- Okay, ready?
It actually feels kind of good
'cause his forehead is really soft.
- I've never heard that before
and that is the most
epoch compliment ever.
- I think that's 20 seconds.
- Now she's
- Okay.
- Is it?
- All right.
- That was pretty intimate.
- Yeah,
- But.
- Forehead to forehead.
- In a good way.
- It worked out.
- Truth or dare?
- Ah, dare.
- I dare you to hug me for a whole minute.
- Absolutely get over here.
- Um hm.
- Very close.
(gentle music)
- Mm hm.
- Okay.
- Yeah, all right.
That was cool, yeah.
It was less awkward than the face to face,
I think that's 'cause we've
already done that now,
so it's not that weird, but like.
- Yes, we kind of broke the touch.
- Initially the hug is, like
you hug people all the time,
you never just be like.
Come here.
That's never how you say hello to people.
- [Hinano] Yeah.
- Truth or dare.
- Uh truth.
- If you could change
one thing about yourself,
what would it be and why?
- I wish I was taller, I
wish I was like six feet.
- How tall are you?
First off.
- I am five three.
- Yeah you want to be like a WMBA?
- I want to be like giant,
- Really tall.
I wanna be like towering over.
- Where people ask you to
get things on the top shelf.
- Well I don't want to do that.
- That's what you would
change, this here, height.
- Yes.
- You'd stretch yourself out.
Okay, cool.
- Stretch myself out.
- You'd stretch yourself out.
- Like elongated.
- Inverted table, you'd
just let yourself hang
like a mat and eventually, you'll grow.
- This is the end of the game, I guess.
- I guess we're done.
All right this was nice.
I feel like we know each
other a little bit more
than you probably would
have on a regular date.
- Absolutely.
- Or yours yesterday.
(laughing)
- This is kind of cool,
I feel like people should
do this more often.
- I think so too.
- They should just carry cards around.
- All right, all right,
well this was amazing.
- So fun.
But take care.
- See ya too.
(upbeat music)
(logo whooshing)